now despite some lingering vaccine
hesitancy in germany there has been a
rush for jabs temporary vaccination
centers are being set up to meet rising
demand for the shots now we have a video
that shows a huge line of people of more
than 2 000 who queued up in hamburg to
get vaccinated inside the city's alpha
harmony concert hall some waited up to
90 minutes to get inside around
two-thirds of participants were
receiving their first or second jabs
while one-third were there for a booster
shot
germany is one of the 60 countries to
make boosters available dw reporter joel
dalroy is tracking how the rollout is
going joel you know some are talking
quite a bit about booster shots we're
talking about booster shots but
officials seem to be torn why is that
well there's concern that wealthy
countries are using the majority of
vaccine doses for their booster shots
and leaving poor countries unprotected
and i can show you some numbers that
illustrate this vaccine inequality
uh up to date 53 of the world's
population has been partially or fully
inoculated against covert 19 but only
five percent of people in low-income
countries have even gotten one shot and
the world health organization says that
six times as many boosters are now being
administered as first-time shots in
low-income countries i mean consider
that six times to one in terms of
boosters and first shots so we see a
great disparity there now how is the
rush to administer booster shots and
wealthier nations affecting vaccine
distribution globally well i can give
you an example from right here in
germany the health minister recently
said that germany would stop donating
doses to the kovacs distribution scheme
for developing countries and he said
he's going to do that because germany
wants to hang on to those doses for its
booster shots over the coming months at
the same time there's another issue at
play which is that germany and other
european countries are blocking attempts
to wave the patents on covert 19
vaccines and drugs which campaigners
would say if those patents were waived
it would free up production and would
enable more low-income countries to be
able to produce vaccines thus
compensating for this rush to use
booster shots now i wanted to know from
this group the people's vaccine alliance
who are pushing for this vaccine waiver
i wanted to know what we as individuals
should do when we are offered a booster
shot should we accept that dose or
should we refuse it in the hope that it
goes to someone else who needs it more
somewhere else so i spoke to anna
marriott from the people's vaccine
alliance and i put that question to her
let's have a listen
no i think we have to continue along the
approach take take the public health
advice that our governments are giving
to us if we have an opportunity to take
a booster vaccine then let's do so but
let's
call on our governments it's our
responsibility to call on our
governments to unblock vaccine access
for other countries these are artificial
limits that are that mean that health
workers on the front line in developing
countries are currently trying to save
lives but they themselves are
unprotected and it is immoral that a
higher proportion of people in rich
countries have had a booster vaccine
whilst people in the poorest countries
haven't even seen their first dose there
are solutions on the table to fix that
we need the global community to come
together agree that waiver and and ramp
up production so that we can solve this
access crisis
well the solutions that she was talking
about there in that clip is a proposal
that's going to be on the table next
week at the world trade organization
it's a proposal brought by over 100
countries to waive or temporarily
suspend the patents on covert 19
vaccines and other medications in order
to free up production now the wto will
be debating that next week we know that
germany and the european union are
currently opposed let's see if the
fast-changing pandemic situation and
this rush to use boosters does anything
to change their position in the meantime
dw reporter joel delroy thanks for
walking us through that joel
u.s drug maker pfizer is speaking
approval for its experimental antiviral
covid19 pill paxlovid in clinical trials
the drug has reduced the rate of
hospitalization or death for adults by
almost 90 percent dw's michael hartlapp
reports
this could be an important new weapon in
the fight against the pandemic a pill
called pexlovit
according to its manufacturer pfizer the
drug has a very high efficacy when taken
up to five days after the patient first
develops covet
about an symptoms
reduction in
um
hospitalizations and deaths um for
individuals symptomatic with covid
um
it's also a big deal because these are
pills that are easy to take
it's five days
of taking pills twice a day
um
so this means people can have these
pills ready to go in their medicine
cabinets and if they then discover that
they're symptomatic with covet and they
test positive
they can start taking the pills
right away
and not have to go into the hospital
pexlovit acts as a proteas inhibitor
the viral protease is an enzyme that
works like scissors and allows the virus
to replicate in the cells
the drug binds to the enzyme disables it
and thereby prevents the virus from
multiplying
compared to more lupirover another covet
pill produced by u.s truck maker merck
it has a higher efficacy
however with a price tag of 620 euros
for a five-day dose peg sloth it doesn't
come cheap
but pfizer has said it will lower its
prices for poorer countries
this is a small molecule and therefore
an oral
drug in this particular case which means
that it's relatively easy to administer
short course of treatment
um
[Music]
and uh potentially doesn't have to be
that expensive to produce
and doesn't require people to go to
hospital so
very suitable for low and middle income
countries
uh which is essentially our constituency
now it's important to note the figures
are only interim results
other scientists will have to review
pfizer's data and the regulators will
have to check the results
so it's unlikely that paxlovid will be
available before the end of this year